yeah take it
[Music]
hi I'm Jessica Kirsten and I'm here to
answer the internet again would you
rather date a girl who constantly
sneezes on you or who constantly farts
during sex this is a tough one I think
someone a girl who constantly farts
during sex because I'm a worthless piece
of [__] and I deserve to be farted on
debate the internet if you had to pick
one person to be the ambassador for the
human race to meet Aliens who would it
be Richard Simmons because I just feel
like he's the most masculine and I feel
the most safe with him didn't something
ridiculous happen with him well he
didn't
I think this is about the background
you're pretty hard didn't his wife
kidnap him
no I think he got an eggplant stuck in
his [__]
and some aliens had to get it out
uh debate the internet
oh [__] off
do you know who I am I'm trying to make
it easy all right can I get an egg white
omelette
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out of a bar for this is very
embarrassing one time I was at a bar and
I sometimes I feel very sexual when I'm
drinking and I finished my beer I
dropped my pants and I shoved it in my
[__]
and they threw me out and I was like my
stepbrother is Zach Braff
and you should not be treating me like
this if there was stats available for
every aspect of your life what what one
stat would you want to see how many
times I've cried I haven't cried a lot
it's why I'm heavy I hold a lot in mom
sometimes I make myself cry where I I
put on Journey like Who's Crying Now and
Then I just when I'm in the car I I
force myself to cry I sometimes cry
after sex really yeah after I I fake an
orgasm I'll cry that's what I want to
know how many orgasms I think if I got
like six right now really
oh my God that's amazing if you could be
part of the crew from any TV show or
movie what crew would it be probably
intervention
[Laughter]
just so that it keeps me in check
because I'm a minute away from relapsing
what is one thing that someone can say
that makes you immediately hate them you
should just be happy why aren't you just
happy I'm like why don't you just die I
hate when people say that to me look if
I could just be happy I would be you
[__] piece of [__]
like why don't you just eat better okay
sure like I have a problem you [__]
would you bang your cousin to win the
Powerball I would bang my daughter
[Laughter]
please don't ever put that on me
okay if you could be the patron saint of
something what would it be I think I'd
be the patron saint of dildos
basically if any lesbian has lost a
dildo I should be the patron saint of
dildos
they should pray to me
and then they'll find it
a sex tape with any two movie characters
who would it be I I I gotta tell you the
fantasy has always been Tom and Jerry
um there's always been this sexual uh
Chemistry Between the two kind of
tension
um Jerry's the little one right
yes I would think so it's the littler
name of two yeah I'd like to see Jerry
plow Tom
just get on top and be like yeah take it
[Music]
oh my God my back
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out